all recoveries are associated with
recoveries in housing every one of them
except the Great Recession this last one
well it's my pleasure to introduce my
esteemed co-worker and co-author Steve
your stead and Steve and I have been we
started about five years ago following
the Great Recession we were determined
to understand what this was all about
and we looked at the last 14 recessions
that's back through the Great Depression
and his housing housing housing together
with mortgage markets that's what really
surprised us and I'm going to now we're
doing a book for cami's University Press
and you know we're getting close to the
finish line the stuff Steve's going to
talk about is new stuff that's not in
the book yet we have that chapter yet to
write and the butt but I want to give
you a little thumbnail sketch of kind of
what we've been doing I don't only and
try to eat too much in the Steve's time
but the the most impression and the
depression is that they are balance
sheet crises the reason why monetary
policy doesn't work is because there's
too many entities banks and households
in negative equity they're paying down
debt they're hunkering down okay in
protection mode and the flows of
spending do not behave the same and the
same and for the same reason fiscal
policy doesn't work okay I had 60 years
ago i sat in alvin Hanson's class at
Harvard
he taught the macroeconomics and he said
well you know in in in bed depressions
monetary policy doesn't work you have to
use fiscal policy and the proof that
that works was that the increase in
government spending in 1940-41 finally
brought them brought us out of the
depression I'll tell you what's wrong
with that in nineteen forty we had had
10 years of balance sheet repair lots of
bankruptcies lots of failures the
homeowners loan corporation had bought
about a million mortgages and reissued
them marked them to market okay so by
1940 the balance sheets were in pretty
pretty good shape then things start to
work okay if I were to show you just one
slide about what Steve and I have been
up to it would be this this is the last
14 recessions and shown in shadow r are
each of the recession's notice that the
Great Recession this is housing
expenditures as a percentage of GDP this
is the most volatile component in the
national income accounts housing it's
very volatile and you see that in this
chart now the Great Recession you'll
notice that housing expenditures fall
for what about it I can't see over there
but I think it falls for eight straight
quarters before the recession begins you
might say well isn't that a lot of lead
time what are the policy makers doing
why aren't they doing something about it
i'll tell you the problem suppose you
were aware of it and you and you move to
stop it then you would be blamed for the
crash you see and the so that is that is
the conundrum that we that we face and
now look back here in the depression and
you'll see why it is
that it's the same old same old we had
Steve and I argue that the Great
Depression was essentially a housing
mortgage market of balance sheet crunch
and the details are in the book it's not
proven it's the data are much better and
more compelling in the Great Recession
than the art of the depression if we
only succeed in getting economic
historians to completely ruin the
depression we will I feel we would have
succeeded notice here though ah that
housing almost always leads the declines
is a couple of spectacular false
positives both of them had to do with
war spending the Korean War and the
Vietnam War all recoveries are
associated with recoveries in housing
every one of them except the Great
Recession this last one is the only one
if you want to call this one a recovery
okay this chart shows you the total
value and trillions of dollars of all
housing in the United States okay all
the entire stock of homes and then down
here at the bottom you'll see debt and
in between is equity that's the value of
all homes minus the outstanding mortgage
debt against them this is a spectacular
ah balance sheet crunch this is what I
noticed that that you have debt going up
somewhat less than proportionally to the
value of all homes and and not
necessarily going in price you're
building more okay that's just total
value to some extent but to
since 1997 of course there's meant there
was a lot of price increases but a flood
of new homes coming in that investment
flattened in 2006 and started down
notice that debt the bottom continues to
rise and you've got today we got
twenty-two percent homeowners still in
negative equity they're not in the mood
to spend and you see the crunch then is
on that equity and and notice here that
in 1997 a total home equity was a about
a little over six trillion okay yes a
little over six trillion it fell below
that finally in 2012 we've risen above
that 15 years for home equity to get
back to it where it was in 1997 now the
smaller recessions here's some here's
four of them you'll notice these these
are the same charts of value debt and
equity the crunch is far smaller and in
all of those cases the Federal Reserve
did not lose control of housing
stimulation through lowering interest
rates of course one of the reasons why
it was pumped up in the first place was
because of Fed policy there's kind of a
Stephen I identify what you might call a
Fed policy a housing a mortgage market
cycle okay and it's in its pan is pretty
regular okay I'm going to turn it over
to Steve Steve great guy to work with
he's a bulldog on data and it's been a
tremendous pleasure now for five years
and we're we're not finished but we're
going to finish the book but we're not
finished thinking
Thank You burden okay thank you thank
you and I'd also like to thank David not
and Amy pause here for the invitation to
come and present it to this audience
it's a real privilege it's also been a
great privilege to work with Vernon for
these past five years we you know he's
so incisive with the questions and
always keeping the research on track so
it's been a lot of fun what I'm going to
talk about is you know burdens described
for you the origins of the problem we
all kind of know that the problem came
out of the housing market there was an
attempt to stimulate our way out of a
persistent recession in 2001 it was a
shallow one but it was very difficult to
get especially business investment going
so the Fed thought that they would try
to stimulate that the house would they
keep interest rates very low try to
stimulate the housing market and get
things going again and that attempt went
awry and we wanted to understand you
know what has happened in other
countries that have faced similar
circumstances so last night nick
gillespie mentioned that there have been
a number of these instances in other
countries and we want to examine those
and see what we've you know he actually
mentioned the the work by carmen
reinhart and Ken Rogoff and they've gone
through and looked at about 20 of these
instances and but they've looked at them
cross-sectionally we want to look at
them in terms of the sequence of events
the time series and try to get some
ideas about causality what's moving
first and what's moving later they're
just looking at things like you know we
find that deep recessions are associated
with deep declines in housing prices but
we'd like to know if they precede or
follow if their cause or a consequence
of the deep downturn they also look at
the build-up of government
that that typically follows one of these
deep downturns we want to know where
that's coming from and it turns out to
be pretty simple you know you get it one
of these deep downturns and there's
about fifty percent increase typically
uh excuse me about fifty percent of the
increase in government deficits is
coming from increased expenditures a lot
of them are just so called automatic
stabilizers kicking in and then there's
about half of the increase in deficits
is coming from reduced tax revenues and
you know so it's a consequence of the
downturn not a cause and so when we look
at the sequence of events we can start
to put together at least a qualitative
model you know we don't have an
analytical model like some of the macro
economists have but we also kind of know
that those analytical models aren't very
good there was a fellow from the
Minneapolis bed who was asked to testify
before Congress about why they couldn't
foresee the recession coming and he said
that the models aren't very good at
predicting rare events his colleague had
recent just a couple years earlier
published a book called the great
depressions of the 20th century so I
just noticed i just realized a few weeks
ago that he had just kind of thrown his
colleague under the bus right in front
of Congress so what i want to do is look
at some of these episodes and compare
two different approaches so one approach
is you know spearheaded especially i
think the most the most visible
proponent of this would probably be Paul
Krugman and perhaps Larry Summers and
Nick had some quotes from both of them
yesterday so very said that if the
government borrows a lot that that's
going to help their credit not hurt it
maybe but it's certainly I I don't think
there's any evidence that it's going to
help
economy and that's kind of what we're
interested in so here's a chart of real
GDP in Japan over the past 36 years and
the blue line in the middle is their GDP
it's on the Left axis I've kind of
intermingled revenue and expenditures on
with a right axis scale and their gdp on
the Left axis scale and I think that's
just I've done that because you can see
that there are really kind of three
periods there's a period of very strong
growth from 76 to 90 and that period
actually you know extended back in the
past into the late 50s they had they had
a very very strong growth for about 30
years and maybe 35 and then they had an
asset market bubble collapse in the
equities market so the Nikkei index
peaked in December of 1989 at about just
under forty thousand and the last time I
looked it was still under 10,000 okay so
they're their equities market is worth
about a fourth what it was worth now
twenty years ago so soon we'll have to
rename this thing this episode from The
Lost Decade to the lost quarter century
or something like that and then there's
a middle period following the crash of
the equities market actually the real
estate market collapsed too and they're
real estate market collapse has been
much in some ways much worse than ours
the the last time that I looked they had
had 17 consecutive years of declines in
inflation-adjusted values of up homes of
residential structures so that's that's
a really significant decline and but
they were they were basically trying to
patch over all the problems for about
six years and then they lost control of
it in
d7 and in 97 they began an even more
aggressively essentially doubled down on
this program of trying to increase
government expenditures and reduce
taxation so I think that you know one
thing that there are a couple of things
that this shows pretty clearly i think
it's just very difficult for paul
krugman and for larry summers to sustain
their argument that you can spend your
way out of these problems another thing
that i think it shows is that deficit
spending is probably quite harmful and
and in conjunction with some other other
evidence that i'll show you from
countries that have recovered sharply I
think there's even stronger a stronger
case that deficit spending doesn't help
okay so the the you know the this is the
democratic program up here let's
increase expenditures and here's the
Republican program let's decrease taxes
and stimulate the economy that way and I
think that there is evidence that it
doesn't work and there's a fairly simple
reason that it doesn't work which I'll
be coming to later when we see what does
work or what has worked in the past and
some other countries so I'm going to
just now turn to some countries that
have had similar crises and that have
recovered there's a quite a bit of
information on this chart but there's a
fairly simple interpretation of it we've
just referenced everything to the first
quarter up to or to the peak of their
economic cycle which in this case was in
the first quarter of 1990 and then all
the numbers on these series are how
things how different sectors that were
performing yeah what the percentage
change was for that sector from that
start of the recession okay so for
example investment was this is fixed
investment so this would be residential
structures and farms investments in
plants and equipment and that was about
thirty five percent
lower five years before excuse me four
years before the recession started and
it peaked just before the recession and
then collapsed and it collapsed so that
at the bottom of the recession total
fixed investment was about half what it
had been ok so that's a very substantial
collapse in fixed investment and that's
what we've seen in all of these serious
episodes that we've seen that the total
collapse in fixed investment so this is
residential structures office buildings
firms new plants and and maybe
manufacturing equipment that goes into
those plants those can actually
quantitatively account for almost the
entire downturn and and that this is
consistent across recessions I excuse me
across these very deep recession
instances and you know further evidence
of that is that here's this blue line is
consumption of nondurable goods and
services and that's pretty close to flat
in the United States that accounts for
sixty percent of GDP okay so and in
Finland it was about fifty I think just
slightly over fifty percent of GDP so
you've got a big part of GDP that's not
moving at all and something else has to
be you know but the causal factor or at
least the part of the economy that's
that's declining rapidly and I'm going
to just skip were to slide and say a
little bit more about this investment
collapse it's very similar in its origin
to the United States so here's the price
of residential structures in Helsinki
and also in Finland in general so the
Helsinki one is the black one on top and
Finland in general is below they're both
indexed so that they're 100 in 1970 and
you can see that even by the time that
the recession started in
inland house prices in Helsinki had
dropped from an index of about two
hundred and four down to something like
a hundred and seventy-four so about a
fourteen percent decline in housing
prices before the economic cycle peaked
so that's consistent with you know
people taking out loans on an asset
finding that that asset is no longer
performing well and retrenching and now
the whole sector itself is going to
decline rapidly the construction of new
homes and the and the construction of
other other fixed investments is going
to decline and that was you know we know
that that was true in the u.s. it was
true in Finland and I've got data that
shows that it's true in almost all of
these countries that we've examined that
have had these serious downturns so
going back now and looking at this we
see they had a very sharp decline in
total GDP it was about twelve point six
percent that's the red curve or the red
series and their government deficits got
very large they ran into problems in
their fiscal sector they didn't have the
depth of credit availability that the
United States has or that Japan has and
they were forced into a retrenchment you
can see that before they even started to
emerge from the depth of their
depression they had a sharp reduction in
government expenditures that's the black
curve here and they persisted for quite
some time it was really quite a long
time before it even came back to the
level that it had been when it peaked in
the middle of the depression so that's
more evidence that you don't need a
fiscal stimulus in order to our
so-called stimulus it's even a misnomer
from my perspective it doesn't it
doesn't help the economy
but it's not needed because we've seen a
strong recovery in Finland I mean you
can see that these growth rates were
good and they've remained good their
economy is more than fifty percent
bigger than it was when their Depression
started in nineteen ninety the total
size of the Finnish economy has
increased over fifty percent the total
size of the Japanese economy over that
period has increased by eight percent so
that's I think fairly strong evidence
that this isn't a helpful response what
is helpful is that they had a sharp
depreciation of their currency and so
what I'm going to turn to now really you
know I'll show you some other countries
and it reinforces the evidence that I've
already shown you but what I'm going to
turn to now is what does help with
repair in one of these balance sheet
recessions what is repairing the balance
sheets and that too is fairly simple you
know as you know i think you know part
of the you know the i don't know what
you call it but you know that the
reasons description is pre mines and
free markets we should expect the free
market to repair these problems in some
way we believe that they should and in
fact they do and in a very particular
way if households are saturated in debt
if there's no room for you know new
investment in fixed structures plants
and equipment houses and office
buildings and so forth that markets
saturated and you know the consumption
spending of households can't increase a
lot because people don't have the income
to do that with there's only really one
place that the recovery can come from
and that's going to be the export sector
and it makes perfect sense because part
of the problem with the fixed investment
sector was that there was capital
flowing in from the rest of the world it
was being used to to provide loans that
were bidding up the price of new
structures
existing structures and that's evidenced
by this blue line down here this is the
current account deficit it's really the
same it's essentially the same as the
trade deficit with the modification that
it also includes income flows on current
debts and assets in the rest of the
world but you can think of it as being
approximately equal to the trade deficit
and that was about six percent of GDP in
Finland for a fairly long period of time
in the u.s. it reached just a shade
under six percent in 2006 when we took
in almost eight hundred billion dollars
from the rest of the world and we were
using that to bid up the prices of
houses and they were the mortgages on
those houses were then bundled into
mortgage securities and shipped off to
the rest of the world okay so we were
accepting large capital inflows and
that's been a typical part of these
downturns so what do they have to do in
that circumstance they've got to start
repaying that debt and the way you repay
it is that you export more than you
import if you add then you're going to
be earning all this money from exports
and that can be used to pay down the
existing debts and to build up assets a
lot of the discussion that goes on about
what we need in order to recover i think
is kind of is a kind of all backward
because people will talk about how we
want to build confidence and then we're
going to we're going to attract foreign
investment we don't want foreign
investment we want to be investors in
the rest of the world now because we've
been in a situation of having the rest
of the world invest in us for about a
quarter century and and we have an
accumulated amount of debts that we need
to repay so what happened in Finland is
that they went from a six percent
current account deficit to a six percent
surplus and very quickly that is
reflected in the export you can also see
where part of the nervousness is coming
from in the rest of the world
because as a percentage of GDP and even
in absolute terms finish exports this
red line right here we're declining but
that's going to be what they need to
repay all of the capital investments
that have been made by the rest of the
world their imports were about flat and
their exports were declining when their
currency depreciated after the financial
crisis they quickly went into a position
of very substantial trade surpluses and
got export earnings so when the rest of
the world says we can't give you any
more capital we don't have faith in your
ability to repay this they make their
own they export more than the import and
they're suddenly generating the capital
that they need and in fact what we
typically see is a real spike in the
exchange or this is a collapse of their
exchange rate when when this graph goes
up because it's actually worth me taking
a moment to describe why this is
inverted in about the middle of 91 they
could take five of their finnish markka
and buy a basket of European currencies
but two years later they need take seven
of their marca to buy those so the value
of the market has fallen but when the
value of the mark of falls it's a lot
they're their exports are much more
attractive to everyone else it costs
less for them to buy them and imports
from the rest of the world become more
expensive to them so they you know
there's there's actually not a decline
in imports but there's a rapid surgeon
exports we're looking now into the
dynamics of this recovery process and we
have a lot of evidence that we're
putting together that the increase in
imports after a sharp depreciation is
typical but that it's coming from
the components that are a part of the
exports so their imports of consumer
items turn to fall but they tend to
increase their exports their imports of
components of production that going to
exports that's also important in terms
of trade policy the last thing you want
to do in response to one of these events
is to you know add to tariffs or do
anything that's going to obstruct that
process of internationalization of
production and in terms of the I think
that covers the basics of the of the
export surge and I'm just going to say
one more thing here about their fiscal
retrenchment and that is that it was
very sizeable they cut within two years
from the bottom of their depression they
cut their total expenditures by five
percent and within seven years they cut
them by almost sixteen percent of GDP
this isn't five percent of their total
government expenditures it's five
percent of GDP and and sixteen percent
within seven years so for us that would
be about a three hundred billion
dollar-a-year reduction year after year
and that should be the target when when
people were talking you know even the
Republicans we're talking about
expenditure reductions and they said we
want to cut expenditures by a trillion
dollars in 10 years they need to do a
lot more than that if they want to be on
the track that these other countries
have followed and so I think that the
goal has been set a bit too low and you
know in terms of what happens to the
export sector I'm just going to run
through briefly a simple example of it
so imagine that you have a Finnish
forest products perm and this firm
produces lumber that it sends to the
United States the market was for market
to the dollar in 1992 and it quickly
depreciated 26 market to the dollar so
if they had $1000000 of exports to the
United States they would get four
million marca back for that almost all
of their costs are incurred in Finland
and say that those were three point six
million marca they've got about a ten
percent profit margin and they earn four
hundred thousand marca after it
depreciate Stu six market to the dollar
they get six million markup for those
for those same exports and their cost
structure isn't affected at all if you
know it's mostly you know mills that are
operating thin in Finland with power
from finished rivers and they're
shipping it on trucks that they have in
Finland bringing them to the port and so
forth so all the costs remain in Finland
and now they've got a margin of 2.4
million marca it's pretty substantial
increase about a six-fold increase in
their profit margins and we've already
seen a couple slides back that they
about many of these countries have about
doubled that their quantity of exports
so their profit margins go up
substantially and their quantity of
exports go up substantially so that's
the source of the recovery that's the
engine of the recovery and that's how
depreciation works economists have
talked about these things as twin crises
in fact Carmen Rogoff Carmen Reinhart
and Graciela Kaminski did this and they
said that you know you can't you
frequently find a financial crisis
coupled with a currency crisis it's a
crisis for people who have taken on
large amounts of foreign debt to build
office buildings and to take out big
mortgages on homes it's a it's an
opportunity for people who are engaged
in productive activities and I think it
should be viewed that way I think that
by viewing the currency decline as a
negative for people who have large
accumulated debts in investments that
are unsound that's basic
kind of backward looking they're looking
at protecting bad investments in the
past if they just let the currency go
then they're going to be you know
looking at a way to progress yeah so as
soon as the thai baht collapsed then
their exports surged you can see they
actually went from about forty percent
of GDP to about sixty four percent of
GDP and that happened in three quarters
nine months you know so something's
going on and in fact you know you can
see the kinds of places where it's going
on here's the the Thai stock index which
peaked in 1994 collapsed and and the
collapse only accelerated during the
financial crisis but here's one
export-oriented firm and what happened
to them one of the things that we've
seen and actually in terms of an
investment strategy that's very helpful
is that it takes the market a while to
recognize this they start to see the
performance of these export oriented
countries and then the prices of the
stocks get bit up but when you look at
what has happened to the revenues of the
country's those increase very rapidly
I'll give you another example from
Iceland and here's here's a company
merrell food systems they build they
build processing equipment that goes on
large ships for for fish harvesting and
processing and their revenues quadrupled
actually you can see 2008 is the crisis
year and their revenues doubled by 2010
I've been very careful to take out
acquisitions so they fortunately
acquired a firm and then divested that
same firm and so so this is on the basis
of the same the same operations their
revenues doubled between two thousand
eight and 2010 and look at what happened
to their profits you know their profit
margins went from under 32 over nine
percent and that persisted
because of the depreciation so there's a
real opportunity and what we'd really
like to do is instead of you know
grubbing around and trying to find a few
examples sort of systematize this with
with somebody who or with with a firm
that's that is you know has the access
to these data and can work on this
problem